let's talk about a new law oh yeah this
guy we got a story from the post
millennial california lawmaker who
relaxed punishments for sex offenders
proposes mandatory drag queen 101 class
for k-12 students
so
when the left demands something and the
gop ignores it they get it when the left
demands something and the gop pushes
back they recoil and then demand
something twice as bad
so we have all of these stories you may
have seen the story where
there's a big neon sign saying it's not
gonna lick itself and children are
dancing and with with sexualized adult
performers at a nightclub that was doing
a family event which is not for families
but uh they're claiming it is and in
response to this this guy is like why
don't we make it mandatory in schools
because this is what they want to do
in response to a texas state
representative announcing he will file
legislation to ban drag shows from
having children in their audience
california state senator scott winer is
it is it weiner or weiner i'm gonna go
with
proposed offering drag queen curriculum
in schools responding to a tweet from
brian slatten of texas he said this guy
just gave me a bill idea offering drag
queen 101 as part of the k through 12
curriculum attending drag queen's story
time will satisfy the requirements so i
don't think he's completely serious you
know i think he's just meant like poking
the bear
but the fact that they've gone beyond
defending it and are now publicly being
like let's do more let's do more let him
keep saying it i know that's how i feel
too i mean this the end of the day we're
sort of it's not a mystery why there's
going to be an absolute tsunami and it's
not just this stuff it's not just the
over-sexualization of children it's also
the fact that parents over the last two
years were watching their kids on zoom
and things right oh this wasn't very
impressive this wasn't very good and
i now know i mean if you look at the
test scores out of where i live
montgomery county maryland used to be
like
65 to 75 percent of kids were sort of
adequately prepared to do algebra in
middle in middle school the latest
testing is
15
and so parents aren't just seeing this
but they're seeing this instead of
gaming gamify algebra for kids where
they get tokens racist
in homeschooling i mean this is this is
the beauty of you know opening the
market like
there's a viral video going around where
someone said that he went into this
event
and there was a little boy
and then someone like the bartender
asked him if he was gay and he said no
and his mom went yes he is he is gay he
says no i'm not you got really angry
munch housing it's much cousin
or or i don't know if that's i don't
know if that's munchausen that's
ver like a mother who's like i'm a
special mom i have a special she wants
to fit in she wants to be a part of
whatever this is
i i don't know how many of these parents
there actually exist i mean i would like
to know if this guy actually has
children because at the end of the day
so heroes of liberty the books that i do
we were just reviewed by current affairs
and the reviewer had no children he's
like the socialist with cats and he has
no children and he's like this is what
parents should be teaching their
children this is what they should not be
but none of them actually have kids they
don't have any say in the game they do
they have your kids right i mean that's
the thing they want to capture our kids
in k-12 kids i so again in montgomery
county where i live the
there was just sort of an announcement
put out on like the mommy
list serves that normally at our
locals zoned elementary school they've
hit 100 kids by now in kindergarten
enrollment
at this point they had 100 kids right
now they have 55 kids signed up for
kindergarten and they're starting to
panic because by june 30th they're going
to start having to fire kindergarten
teachers because they're not going to
have enough
kids registered and they keep on passing
the book they they got federal money
over covid to sort of inflate their
budget
because people were pulling their kids
out but that federal money is now gone
and they're they're screwed i want to
pull up this tweet from libs of tick
tock
who writes the mayor of apex north
carolina announced that the drag queen
part of the pride event has been
cancelled after feedback was received
from citizens but it's more interesting
than that
the letter
from the mayor says
it continues to be my goal to ensure
that all voices in our community are
present are represented i have received
a variety of feedback regarding the drag
queen story hour at the upcoming apex
pride festival given that this part of
the event was not originally presented
when the event was proposed i met with
representatives from the organization
hosting the event the apex festival
commission and presented the feedback
i've received from citizens today i was
notified that the apex festival
commission has taken the feedback into
careful consideration and has decided to
remove the drag queen's story hour from
the event they tried sneaking it in
they didn't announce it they get their
access and permitting whatever they need
and then they add child sexual grooming
they don't even have to sneak it in this
is something that they love doing so i'm
kind of surprised that this was a
response because this is their entire
reason
is like sexualizing children so i don't
know why they had to sneak it in when
it's like normally just you know part of
pride week now
i think they
they know that if parents the average
parent sees this there's going to be a
major backlash i mean but this is not
out of school right like this is just a
public event that people can attend
well so here's an interesting moral
question
there's a martin bailey kind of thing
going on where
in the bailey you have them outright
just
sexualizing kids it's not going to lick
itself and then when you call it out
they retreat and say it's just a costume
party it's oh that's all it is a pageant
show and then and it's like dude they're
sticking dollar bills in thongs there's
photos there's queen lectacia a
nine-year-old boy touching a nude adult
man in a photo shoot these are grooming
kids sexually that is overt abuse yeah
yeah no i i i don't get it yeah and
of course they were also talking about
drug abuse and and there's different
layers of this i think this all kind of
coincides with a larger depopulation
agenda if we go down the rabbit hole but
but to me there's a lot of different
aspects of this that really do need to
be understood here and parents being
responsible for their children is one of
them i feel like a lot of them feel that
they could just give a screen give a
computer put them on netflix and their
child is going to be okay and they're
not you need to be a part of your
child's life and you used to be able to
outsource you used to be able to put
your kids in front of disney and and
bring them to the school library now i
mean especially in the month of june if
you go to your local library and you
look at the children's section it is
wall to wall
may i just say that i am absolutely in
love with the fact that they are turning
parents into a voting block
i wish them the best of this because
this transcends everything this
transcends class race it transcends
whether you're gay or straight if you
have kids and you care about your kids
you're going to push back on this so
hard yep you're going to flip their boat
it's going to be great well we saw it
with glenn yunkin and they i mean i it
was funny i met this mom at a at a dance
my kid does a dance class in you know
very blue maryland and she walked up to
me and she sort of gave me a little bit
of her backstory and we were texting
later to you know get our kids together
and i was like oh you're one of those
blue red pilled moms from glut for glen
yunken and she's like you bet i am
because i saw what they were doing to my
kids on zoom and i and they did not care
i mean it's not just that
that they didn't do it well it's that
they just did not care and so
what really frustrated me about this
call for everyone to enroll their
kindergartner in school
or the kindergarteners teachers will
lose their jobs when did the
kindergarten teachers express any
concern over children over the last
years i know that the the unions were
sort of the larger villains but i didn't
see that many teachers coming out and
saying we need to be in person and i
need to teach reading without masks on
myself for the children we did not see
that in mass yes and the psychological
negative impacts of the mask wearing of
specifically the distance learning is
going to have long-term consequences for
children that are not going to be able
to be socially uh you know available to
turn an entire generation into and i
don't say this in a in a bad way
into autistic you're they they are not
going to be able to form these social
bonds my my kid does occupational
therapy and most of the occupational
therapists patients are on the autism
spectrum and they've told us like
this is bad or have good human
interactions with you know the fellow
fellow children and fellow friends and
another aspect of this to really kind of
ascertain is that they're not going to
be able to have healthy relationships
whether with friends or with partners or
lovers and then you have the aspect of
pornography and how readily available it
is and how it literally rewires
children's brains and then you and then
you teach people not to have you know
you're essentially leading people down
the pathway where they're going to be
alone and miserable for the rest of
their life and i think this is all done
on purpose because then you have the
perfect consumer when you could you
could you could control someone you
could enslave someone when they're an
individual but when they're a family
when they're a group or in their unit
it's harder to control and subjugate a
population if you want to explain to
people who don't understand the damage
masks do it's actually quite simple
set the volume on a tv
just low enough to where it's kind of
hard to hear yeah and then
have have something play on the tv and
then ask this person what they said and
they'll tell you then block their view
of the person's mouth and play it again
and they'll say i couldn't hear it yeah
but why the volume's the exact same and
then learn how to read that way i mean
what one of the most underreported sort
of stories of all the school stuff is
the violence in schools and people are
like why we wouldn't see this coming
when you dehumanize children put them in
literal glass boxes don't let them go
near anyone and tell them that they are
vectors of disease for two years
there's gonna be some anger and then
over sexualize them and confuse them
with all these other things screen where
they're
ready access to the pornography exactly
and i i wasn't michael malus who said
that schools
are
maybe the place uh the one place where
children experience violence or
something like that yeah what do you say
on par with prisons i think yeah
yeah yeah the same people who build the
prisons build the schools so what do you
expect i mean especially when you look
at the larger or uh people call an
education education system it's it's
again an institution that indoctrinates
children for the political benefit of
the people controlling that institution
and this is why david rockefeller was
instrumental in creating the modern day
education system trying to create
factory workers that were going to be
good workers for him and no one else
treat everyone exactly the same and
everyone sort of goes through the
machine are you familiar with john
taylor yes
he does incredible work and if you don't
know who that is you should definitely
join taylor so he was an ed he was a
teacher actually he won teacher of the
year in new york city and during his
speech he sort of stood up and said this
entire machine is broken we treat
children as cogs in a machine and we
it's unnatural to teach anything when
you tell them okay read this poem and
then a bell dings and then they have to
move on it it treats children as if they
are
rats basically absolutely yeah and the
home school philosophy that we fought
because i homeschool all my kids oh not
all of them obviously i have a baby but
um it's called charlotte mason and it
just basically yeah and it talks about
sort of
her entire philosophy is
the respecting the personhood of
children and treating every child
as an individual and it's a this is what
the education system should be and you
know there are charlotte mason schools
that i mean this is this is why people
are are flocking away from public
schools because they treat children
homeschooling is on the rise which i
think is is absolutely incredible
absolutely awesome pods are also
starting to exist entire networks are
starting to exist where people in a
community are coming together and saying
hey i'm a physicist hey i'm a
mathematician hey i know history on the
way here i was talking to an art teacher
she homeschools her kids and i said can
you teach an art class for all of the
other jewish explorers in our community
i was literally on the phone with her on
the way here there's huge networks
popping up and a lot of people weren't
talking about this new hampshire just
passed a lot of new legislation allowing
people to
homeschool even more freely and even
have more access to taxpayer funds
if they do homeschool and
they have entire communities of
individuals especially a part of the
free state project where you have an
expert in one particular field that
teaches an entire group of children on
the very specific issues that he's an
expert on my freight my friend jay noon
does this with welding he has little
kids welding and building stuff and
constructing stuff he calls it uh i
think he calls it man camp uh he might
get canceled for that
but but j noon does great work and he
literally teaches
young women
young young boys how to build stuff out
of their hands
out of their hands and it's incredible
stuff what they're able to do when
they're
taken out of this confined space where
they're told just to regurgitate
something right and they're told hey you
have free reign to create something and
the things they come up with is
absolutely incredible these kids have so
much potential they have so much
creative energy they have so much
incredibleness within them and the
school system the indoctrination system
intentionally suppresses that to make
them good slaves people think when you
say indoctrination system that it's you
know you're sort of feeding all this
drag queen stuff which obviously is
happening but i think that the larger
point of indoctrination isn't and the
damage isn't
that messaging the progressive messaging
which i obviously think is really
damaging it's treating children like
they are cogs and like rats
rinse and repeat say this and
learning remember this think about how
we read books in in school they you have
to write a book report and then you have
to illustrate it and then you have to
and
i hated the book by the end of it i
never wanted to see it again and then
when i read it as an adult i'm like oh
gravestone's wrath is actually really
pretty good it's a pretty good read and
so i'm reading i'm rereading all of this
classic literature as an adult and i'm
like you
murdered this piece of beautiful
literature and i mean this is schools
all of us yeah i mean the only books
that uh millennials read have read is
harry potter those are actually good i
defend them sure sure sure i like harry
potter for sure but it's the only thing
they've read
for pleasure i would say i mean this is
this is the problem with um with also
putting kids in a pen for eight hours a
day at the end of the day they're just
fried and then you put them in front of
a screen whatever but they they have no
energy and no inertia to just read for
pleasure
i think we have to expand pods
like so they're really hard to put
together let me tell you as someone who
spent the last three years trying it's
it takes more
coordination because then you have to
rely on other people and i don't know if
you remember group projects when you
were a kid
so never rely on someone else to do it
because no one does it as well as you do
so i don't know if they have these where
you are but in colorado when we were
homeschooling we had these co-ops where
you could go and learn latin and yeah
they're incredible but they're super
hard to form
and then so this is like just my
personality i hate rules and i don't
like people telling me what to do
and a lot of the pod a lot of the co-ops
near us were crazy with kovid and so i
just didn't want to partake and a lot of
them i mean
we sort of fit into a sort of weird
ideological box because we're jewish and
because you know whatever and so it's
hard to sort of find like-minded people
but we're i mean we're trying to form
that where i live but um but it's hard
it's hard to coordinate what about doing
it online coordinating online so we do
so my kids do an online like hebrew
class or whatever and the teacher is
wonderful but i don't want my kids in
front of a screen all day yeah not all
day i would think there are some things
you could learn online so they do so my
kids do
it like it's called gesher and like it's
it's base so the problem with the the
jewish model and like my
experience and my perception is that so
in the jewish community people 95
percent of people send their kids to
jewish day schools like orthodox i'm not
talking about reform so if you actually
like care about your faith um
you will send your kids to these schools
but they're like twenty thirty forty
thousand dollars a pop
and so it it's a kind of birth control
because people are like oh you can only
really afford to have two or three kid
yeah so people have two or three kids
and so
it forms you know
sort of it becomes birth control
basically and so
what some people do but very few people
is that they pull their kids out and i'm
talking like two percent of people
homeschool right now and the woman who
runs this program that my kids do she
runs all of the jewish classes online on
zoom
um but it's hard i mean it's hard for i
mean the the jewish community does not
homeschool on mass and i do not
understand it it makes no sense because
we have the financial constraints of not
just the the tuition but also you have
to live within walking distance of your
synagogue yeah and so there's a jew tax
on on your house because
it's gonna be it's it's the home value
and it's also the property taxes and so
it's really expensive to be jewish which
is like you know there's a reason why
there's all the stereotypes about us
being cheap because we're really tight
things are expensive yeah um kosher food
is also super expensive and so
i don't get why there's not more jewish
home schoolers but i think uh i can
easily attribute much of my success to
the fact that i was homeschooled before
kindergarten so you know when i was
growing up
when i'm a little kid my mom's
homeschooling me from
our earliest memories until we even
started kindergarten
and then i learned later on none of my
friends had any schooling that they were
you know three and four years old doing
very little if anything you know getting
a little bit of instruction from their
parents but mostly nothing i was
actually you know every day we have
grammar books we have math books and
vocabulary and all that stuff
and so i started researching schools
because i despised them completely i did
uh k through eighth grade and then i did
a couple months of high school and then
just stopped completely with all school
yeah so you're there for an idiot was
that they're there for an idiot because
you saw oh oh of course absolutely and
you didn't turn into anything yeah so so
the issue is you know i remember when
the conversation around college was
happening
and
people were surprised to learn you don't
need a high school diploma to go to
college but all of my friends were
convinced they they had to have one and
i was like once you turn 18 you can just
go to community college get an
associates and then train you don't even
have to turn 18. i have a friend when
she realized that she she was completely
sold on homeschooling her her i think
sophomore age in high school he's
already going to community college by
the time he graduates high school at 18
he'll have an associate's yeah exactly
great and so it's a complete waste of
time yeah well i remember when i when
when i was told don't worry high school
is going to be different and then what
was it identical in every way and i was
like
right right i was like how many times
are we going to learn the exact same
things over you're teaching us nothing
so i was like i'm done yeah i went to
new york city public school that was
extremely um brooklyn
uh i don't want to kind of release the
name of it i went to two high schools
and um
when you're there you have teachers that
are absolutely horrible that that
absolutely ruin learning ruin literature
ruin your ability to even you know have
basic you know functions and there's
also you know teachers that do care that
i had teachers going up um i i could i
could i know four of them off the top of
my head that used to say okay this is
what they want you to learn this is
what's going to be on the test now here
let me tell you how the cia brings and
brings and crack into the poor
neighborhoods here let me tell you about
uh iran contract here let me tell you
about jfk here let me tell you about you
know uh gulf of tonkin and and there was
four teachers throughout my entire uh
life in new york city public school that
were absolutely incredible caring loving
individuals that did a good job that
actually made you understand what the
world was really like but that was rare
yes and the vast majority of them i just
hated school because it was just like
indoctrination i love homeschooling i'm
super raw raw but the problem i think of
conservatives is that we think that
homeschooling is like a scalable
solution for a lot of people it's not so
here's the problem you had four teachers
who were caring and whatever
when you get into the parenting world
and you realize how few parents care
about their own children that i think is
one of the most earth-shattering i've
been saying this and people didn't like
it and i said you've got how many
parents
that would prefer to have a job
knowing it meant their children are
being groomed than to risk their their
comfort and their access to just their
comfort i like i'm just gonna be really
mean for a second it's not just their
comfort it's they just don't want to
spend time with their own children right
and this is something that i truly do
not understand as a parent because and
jordan peterson talks about this who
your children are are basically
under the age of 10 a reflection on you
so if your child is a real
then that means that you're not a great
person either and i always say to my
daughter
because we we have like social issues if
the parent is liberal they sometimes
don't want their child playing with my
child and this has been a reoccurring
issue in our family unfortunately and my
daughter was really disappointed for
some i'm just gonna be honest with you
honey that person is a jerk and their
child therefore is not someone you're
going to want to play with socially
because plus i don't why would you fall
far why would you want your kids hanging
out with them i mean that's exactly it
the child is a jerk and it all i mean
this is people keep on talking about
sort of this your child's socialization
whatever with homeschooling and i'm like
it's a feature not a bug because i don't
have to have my children play with any
of those jerks kids i know who they're
playing with it's not about a jerk
necessarily but it's also about social
contagions yes 100 i was the bad kid in
my class all growing up i was the one
that told all my friends about sex and
drugs because i did not grow up in a
great house oh no i did not grow up in a
great house and i was the one that told
all my friends about do you know what
sex is do you actually do you want to
talk about like you were that person oh
i was awful my gosh i'm protecting my
children from myself at seven that's
great yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you